so they say that those that do not learn
from history are doomed
to repeat it on today's episode of sales
talks money
quarantine edition uh we're going to be
covering whether the 2020s
will be the roaring 20s 2.0 so if you
recall
the roaring 20s it started with a deadly
pandemic reminiscent of today
it then led to massive economic
expansion pretty damn cool
but then it ended the decade with a
major market crash that led
to the great depression so the question
is this a hundred
years later will history repeat
itself again let's talk money all we
talk is money
all we talk is
so what prompted this episode that we're
filming today at my home
in my apartment is an article actually i
saw in the daily mail we'll put the
article up right here and it basically
says
economists at ucla have predicted that
we get ready
for another roaring twenties pretty damn
cool
now here are a couple of predictions
that these ucla economists
make number one they say that you can
expect a
surging economic growth after effective
covet vaccines
become widely available uh economists
also predict a gloomy
coveted winter don't i know it i'm
sitting here at home
with covid right now social distancing i
feel fine
but still filming this episode why
because the show must go on my friends
so they're predicting back to that
they're predicting a gloomy
coped winter then a spring and summer of
mass vaccinations followed by strong
economic growth so this economic growth
is not only just for 2021 the year that
we are in right now
but for the entire upcoming decade and i
have some charts
to show you to prove their point so uh
we'll get into that in a second what
these charts show what this article
shows
but before we talk about the future
before we talk about this upcoming
decade
let's revisit the past into the roaring
20s of the 1920s and how it compares
today the 1920s the roaring 20s it was
the time of the great
gatsby um it was a period of great
social political and economic change
does that ring a bell to anyone because
it does to me great social political and
economic change
definitely rings a bell with where we
are today in 2021 so this is a time
where after the great war which is known
as world war one now
any devastating spanish flu which would
be akin to today's
coronavirus situation that we got going
on pandemic pandemic however you want to
call it
but the bottom line was that after all
that after the war
after the spanish flu life was in full
swing due to pent-up demand young people
partied their asses off
and i'm sure my young friends out there
would love to party their asses off
just like the good old days despite
prohibition prohibition lasted
throughout the entire
1920s where basically drinking alcohol
was illegal can you imagine that
no alcohol whatsoever yet they were
still partying
so entertainment was in high demand due
to pent-up demand
so music art and movies all influenced
pop culture so that was going on then so
let's revisit the past
what was the music of the day well it
was jazz big band
and swing music ruled the day this would
be today's
pop hip hop and edm music um
of today so movies were huge back in the
day in fact 75 percent of americans
would go to the movies once a week 75
percent of americans would go to the
movies
once a week who would they go to see
well none other than charlie chaplin
now today in today's world since we're
comparing contrasting
that's very reminiscent of what we're
all doing now which is netflix
and chilling and using other streaming
services so that's
a little of the past compared to today
now back then it was all about the rise
of radio everyone got their information
from the radio radio was everywhere this
is very much
like how social media is today
back in the day in actually in 1920 the
19th
amendment gave women the right to vote
who were these women a lot of them were
called flappers these these women were
rebellious women in short hair and even
shorter skirts who they drank
they smoked and they were sexually free
this is very
reminiscent of today's metoo movement
what else there was something called the
harlem renaissance which was progressing
big time this is just like very much
like today's
black lives matter movement sort of a
comparison there penicillin was invented
in the 1920s
this is very much like the covet vaccine
of today
there was booming industries let's talk
money now let's talk about the
industries that what were the industries
there was cars aviation
infrastructure electronics and chemicals
those are some of the big
industries that came about back then
which is very reminiscent of today's
big tech ai 5g and of course
big pharma productivity let's talk about
productivity productivity draws
uh productivity rose dramatically see
here's the covent brain coming in
productivity rose dramatically this was
thanks to henry ford's
assembly line which he used to mass
produce
the ford model t now if i'm drawing a
comparison to contrast
to henry ford this would be akin to
today's elon musk and tesla and the rise
of autonomous vehicles that are that's
common that's common so what else
happened back in the 1920s
consumer debt appeared were all my
friends out there with consumer debt we
all got it
this was um consumer debt appeared this
was um thanks to widespread
bank loans and credit there were not
credit cards but you got it at the bank
we still have that debt problem as we
all know but today we also have a
student loan crisis
so that's a little bit of a different
situation back then versus
today so what else was going on in the
1920s well the government
this is after world war one of the great
war the government wanted people to buy
goods
that were made in the usa resulting in
profits
remaining in the usa ring a bell this is
very reminiscent
of donald trump's american first plan uh
that has that written all over that
not to mention that uh president-elect
joe biden
has his own american build back better
plan
as well you can expect that throughout
the early part of the night of the 2020s
so the economy boomed and this was
fueled by the growth of the stock market
stock market
basically people millions of people drew
in for the first time
being a part of the american stock
market they're like what's the stock
market all about oh my god i gotta get a
part of that
this is very reminiscent of today's gen
z and millennials
starting to use uh robo advisors like
acorns or robin hood or betterment and
wealthfront
stuff like that sort of reminiscent
1920s
2020s of today with the stock market
let's talk about the quote
of the time the quote of the time was by
president
calvin coolidge he said this the
business
of america is business so that was what
was going on in the 1920s
fast forward to today the closest quote
that i can get
to that was by none other than the
rapper jay-z
he says i'm not a businessman i'm a
business
man so that's a little bit compared
contrast 20s to the 2020s
so this was a time in our nation
understand this here's my point this is
the time in our nation
where our nation's wealth more than
doubled so the question is this now
we're doing the
the the 2020s and what to prepare for
are you ready for that to happen
this decade don't forget there was a
crash
at the end of 1920s 1929 to be exact
october
of 1929 where basically the stock market
crash came
from crumbling down and that was at the
very end of the decade which led to of
course
the great depression so that was the end
of the 1920s
now let's talk about what to expect this
upcoming decade
according to these ucla economists
so they saying there's two major factors
that will lead to economic growth
this upcoming decade number one is the
vaccine right i kind of wish i had that
at this point in my life right now
the vaccine and number two pent up
demand there's that pent-up demand again
they're basically saying due to vaccine
and pent-up demand the next few years
the economy
will accelerate and return to its
previous
growth trend speaking of growth trends
let's actually take a deep dive into
these charts
in this article from the daily mail so
here's chart one
chart one is called annualized gdp
growth by quarter and basically i'll sum
it up for you
and we won't get too technical but here
we go in 2019
gdp ranged from 1.5
to 2.9 then in 2020
we reached a low of minus 31.4
in q2 that was obviously at the height
covid
we bounced back strong in q3 to 33
and then flatlined at 1.2 percent in q4
now we're in 2021 economists predict um
a very low 1.8 gdp potentially lower
according to jp morgan in q1 but then
it's expected to surge to 6 in q2 so
that's where the
surge will happen is in q2 and then they
also predict
these ucla economists that in 2021 q3
and q4
all throughout 2022 and 2023 will the
gdp will grow at a consistent three
percent
mark each quarter so essentially what
i'm saying is this 2021 will be a bounce
back year
but 2022 is when the real
growth will occur let's move on to the
next chart project
next chart chart number two is consumer
spending and these economists have
broken it down
into five major categories category
number one is
accommodations which is basically hotels
lodgings places to stay
number two is travel number three is
recreation or leisure
and entertainment number four is
restaurants which we know have been
decimated uh due to covid and number
five
is health care services this is elective
services and non-elective services
so basically what they're saying in
these charts you can see
that driven by pent-up demand there's
that pent-up demand again
there will be a surge in spending and
2021 spending will increase
and reach pre-pandemic levels by 2022.
so chart number three let's move on to
chart number three right now
chart number three is all about
unemployment and the unemployment rate
so in 2019 unemployment range from three
and a half percent
to three point nine percent this is some
of the lowest unemployment
in the last 50 years then obviously in
cove it happened unemployment surged in
q2
it fell to uh well it rose to 13
and then fell from uh into q3 to 8.8
percent at end of the year of 2020
at 6.8 percent now let's fast forward to
what you can expect in 2021 and beyond
basically the economists are predicting
unemployment to slowly dip
from six to five to four percent over
the next three years but they're
basically saying that you can expect
unemployment not to reach pre-pandemic
levels until 2024 at the
earliest 2024 to earliest so what's the
bottom line let me sum up these charts
um real quickly in a sentence or less
they're basically saying all in all
gdp is expected to rise and stay stable
after 2021 and beyond um
spending is expected to go up i broke
down those five categories and you can
see where the spending
will increase but unemployment will
slowly
slowly slowly make its way back but do
not expect unemployment to get back to
pre-pandemic levels
until 2024 at the earliest so here's
what you can expect this decade
here's what you can expect this decade a
couple predictions a couple assumptions
that we can make
number one to all my millennials out
there and gen z
out there that's people basically
between 18 and 40 at this point
millennials will replace the baby
boomers as the largest
generation in us history that's number
one number two we talked about student
loan debt at the beginning of this a
little bit
vocational schools will replace college
for many young people many many people
are basically saying why the hell do i
need to go to college at this point
so vocational schools look out for that
and number three this isn't so much
prediction because it's actually
happening
but you can expect you can expect a
v-shape recovery
where we hit rock bottom and we just
keep climbing and climbing and climbing
the rest of the decade
so those are my three predictions of
what you can expect this upcoming decade
but remember it's not all roses because
what happened at the end
of the 1920s 1929 to be exact
there was a market crash so you can
expect a market crash certainly
by 2030 i would assume that's my
prediction
what do you think when do you think the
next crash is coming
my assumption it will be very much like
history repeating itself
at the end of the 2020s into 2030 there
should be another market crash
so what can we learn from this what can
we learn from this what can we learn
from this episode what can we learn
about
history repeating itself so it's number
one learn from history
and you should appreciate your health if
you've still got it
i got covered right now i'm still doing
this episode why because the show
must go on i feel okay i'm social
distancing but appreciate your health
and build your wealth so what can you do
you should save
that money you should save up to invest
where should you invest
whether it's stock market whether it's
real estate
whether it's crypto whether it's
commodities save
that money to invest but always always
always
keep a cushion we all know that you can
expect just like in 2008 just like in
when everything's going well just like
you're going to expect in the roaring
20s 2.0
there's going to be another market crash
so the question is will you be prepared
when that crash happens again in 2020
i'm sorry in 2030 we'll see if that
happens so
be prepared for that so let me leave you
with this last quote before we wrap this
episode up
here's a quote that is very apropos
today
just like it was in the 1920s this quote
comes
from none other than the man of the
1920s henry ford he says this
coming together is a beginning staying
together
is progress and working together is
success
i today in america we can use a lot of
coming
together and hopefully a lot of success
so that's the end of this episode i hope
you appreciated this episode
coming to you from my covid
quarantine apartment don't judge me i
know the walls are barren
i'm currently moving out of my apartment
and going to florida baby
so if you enjoyed this please like this
episode
subscribe to valuetainment economics if
you have not and check out this episode
right here that i filmed
called biden's economic plan this is
what you can expect
from the uh from the incoming biden
presidency
in 2021 and beyond so with that being
said i appreciate you
and as always save that
[Music]
much